die partei die linke ist auch sein
lebenswerk er war lange fraktionschef
ist jetzt der außenpolitische sprecher
gregor gysi herzlich willkommen zu
phoenix persönlich begrüße sie ebenso
herzlich herr gysi die linke ist in
nordrhein westfalen nicht im landtag in
schleswig holstein nicht sehen sie ihr
lebenswerk in gefahr
auf jeden fall ist sie in einer schweren
existenziellen krise das ist wahr aber
als ich vorsitzender der partei
89 90 war sie in einer noch schwereren
existenziellen krise insofern bin ich
dass ich ein bisschen gewohnt aber
diesmal sind wir selbst schuld damals
waren wir auch selbst schuld aber auf
ganz andere weise erzählt wie fern jetzt
selbst schuld
das hat mehrere gründe erstens haben wir
uns nicht auf schwerpunkte konzentrieren
zweitens haben wir nicht definiert was
ist eigentlich unser stellenwert für die
gesellschaft wessen interessen müssen
wir in erster linie vertreten und welche
interessen dann erst in zweiter linie
und drittens gibt es bei uns eine
demonstration scriba das ist furchtbar
es gibt immer so einen ideologischen
streit und der wird man nach dem motto
geführt ich habe recht alle anderen
heimrecht und das wird dann auch noch
finanziert was wirklich schlimm ist und
das alles zusammen hat glaube ich mit zu
dieser existenziellen krise geführt wenn
sie sagen es wird den und ziehe das ist
ja schon ein heftiger vorwurf
wer steckt dahinter was ist dass wir
bewusst ist nicht immer zu ermitteln
aber wenn zum beispiel gegen unsere
partei pose seinen artikel im spiegel
erscheint dann sind wir informiert
worden von leuten aus der partei oder
wenn gegen sören pellmann dann ein
artikel erscheint sind sie auch wieder
informiert werden von leuten aus der
partei und das ist das was ich bei den
grünen bewundere die streifen sich nicht
weniger als wir aber man die ist so gut
wie nichts davon an den zeitungen bei
uns liest er einen streit schon bevor
stattgefunden macht das muss man erst
mal hinkriegen und das muss unbedingt
überwunden werden also erstens muss klar
werden die partei verliert vertritt in
erster linie die interessen von
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmern und
von auszubildenden und dann kommen noch
viele andere aber das muss der
schwerpunkt sein zweitens brauchen wir
eine reale friedenspolitik wir brauchen
eine politik der sozialen gerechtigkeit
und auch der guten arbeit also es geht
auch um das arbeitsrecht und
mitbestimmungsrechte und vieles andere
und wir brauchen natürlich eine
ökologische nachhaltigkeit in sozialer
verantwortung wir müssen durch grüner
werden als die grünen sondern wir müssen
immer in die soziale verantwortung in
diesem rahmen appellieren und dafür auch
streiten dann brauchen wir die
gleichstellung von frauen man davon sind
wir weit entfernt wir haben wir viele
frauen berufe frauenberuf heißt sei
schlecht bezahlt deshalb gehen wir
männer ja auch nicht hin so einfach ist
es und wir brauchen eine gleichstellung
ost west all das wenn wir uns darauf
konzentrieren und jetzt nicht debatten
führen zur trennung von amt und mandat
oder wie lange dürfen mandate dauern und
dann sage ich natürlich immer ironisch
wir trennen uns ja sowieso jetzt schon
von lothar mandaten nachnamen ach ja die
absolute trennung von amt und mandat
also das kann ja nicht sein ziel sei
auch die diskussion über doppelpunkt
sternchen großes ist jetzt nicht die für
meine partei entscheidende frage und
wenn wir das meistern dann können wir
wieder einen stellenwert für die
gesellschaft bekommen sie haben in ihrem
buch geschrieben die leute müssen
erkennen und nachvollziehen können was
wir wollen also wir die politiker in dem
fall wir sind nicht für uns da wenn wir
etwas für die leute erreichen wollen
müssen wir zuallererst erreichen damit
gerade skizziert mit welchen punkten sie
die menschen wieder erreichen wollen das
ist ja auch erstaunlich dass
ausgerechnet jetzt in einer zeit die so
von krisen und von inflation geprägt ist
die linke tatsächlich jetzt bei den
letzten landtagswahlen nicht realisieren
konnte ja das liegt eben daran dass wir
falsch aufgestellt sind dass wir das in
den medien folgendes nicht deutlich
wurde was ist in unserer partei endlich
eine mehrheitsposition und was ist eine
minderheitenposition
und solange die bürgerinnen und bürgern
den eindruck haben du kannst bei uns
alles haben weil es irgendwie alle
positionen gibt die auch alle
gleichberechtigt sind poliert zu bilden
und weder die wollen genau wissen wofür
stehst du natürlich neben den
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
auszubilden interessieren uns
logischerweise dann auch die kinder die
rentnerinnen und rentner die beamtinnen
und beamten die solo selbstständigen
freiberuflern und freiberufler alles
wichtig auch übrigens die inhaberin und
inhaber kleiner unternehmen und auch von
mittelstandsunternehmen
es ist aus bestimmten gründen wichtig
das müssen wir alles sehen aber die
konzentration die muss man eben
aufspüren und dann müssen wir uns auf
fünf fragen beschränken wenn wir 28
fragen beantworten und das auf jedem
parteitag können die leute auch mit uns
zurzeit nichts anfangen die leute müssen
wissen wozu brauchen wir eigentlich
diese partei das muss deutlich werden
dem gerät parteitag angesprochen der
steht ja auch jetzt wieder bevor bevor
wir darauf kommen würde ich gerne mal
mit ihnen gemeinsam einmal zurückblicken
ziemlich genau vor zehn jahren haben sie
auf dem parteitag in götting ja damals
ihrer user absolut freien lauf gelassen
gehören mal das ist wahr aber in unserer
fraktion im bundestag herrscht auch hass
und hass nicht zu leihen
seit jahren versuche ich die
unterschiedlichen teile zusammen zu
führen seit jahren befinde ich mich
wirklich zwischen zwei lokomotiven die
aufeinander zufahren und ich weiß dass
man dabei zu meint werden kann seit
jahren bin ich in der situation mich
entweder bei der einen oder bei der
anderen gruppe unbeliebt zu machen und
ich bin es leid
es ist jetzt schlimmer oder was damals
schlimmer
also für mich war es damals schlimmer
ich war ja der fraktionsvorsitzende und
die atmosphäre in der fraktion war
furchtbar das hat sich natürlich
geändert weil wir jetzt ja nur eine
fraktion haben weil wir drei
direktmandate erreicht haben mich
vorstelle das erste album mit blumen
begrüßt als ich in die fraktion kam und
mit beifall das hat es schon ewig nicht
mehr gegeben insofern hat sich die
atmosphäre verändert aber auf der
anderen seite ist schlimmer geworden
die wichtigtuerei
dieses ich bewusst sein also zum
beispiel ich erkläre das weil es meine
sicht ist und ich versuche dann immer
zusammen das kann schon sein aber du
fährst ja auf der fahrkarte der linken
also muss es ja auch damit etwas zu tun
haben verstehen sie das ganze ist noch
schlimmer geworden als damals und damals
waren die auseinandersetzung auf der
ebene wir können uns das leisten wir
haben ja so und so viel prozent der
stimmen und jetzt ist es auf einer
anderen ebene damals als wir fraktions
position als zu viel und ich wollte
ihnen das in dieser klarheit sagen
übrigens hatte das durchaus wirkung das
leben danach nach es für mich leichter
der bildungs festzustellen dass ich auch
ziemlich viel deutlich dicker war als
heute zumindest a source und
und deshalb sage ich ja auf der einen
seite war es für mich damals schlimmer
jetzt ist es für die partei schlimmer es
gibt menschen in der partei die
ausgetreten sind mit den worten in
keinem anderen gesellschaftlichen
bereich gebe es ein solches ausmaß an
menschlicher niedertracht wie in der
partei die sich solidarität auf die
fahnen schreibe das ist ja genau das was
sie auch gerade selber skizziert haben
dass das gefühl die partei geschlossen
nach außen
zu bringen dass es daran mangelt
sie als einer ja doch der zentralen
figuren bei den linken haben sie auch
das gefühl dass sie ganz persönlich
fehler gemacht haben also in der zeit in
der ich in der politik bin seit dezember
1989 habe ich zahlreiche fehler begangen
zum beispiel habe ich mich ja auch
geirrt hinsichtlich der einstellung des
ostens ich bin immer davon ausgegangen
für die nächste generation spielt der
osten gar keine rolle mehr das sind
einfach alles deutsche waren schwerer
irrtum
das gewicht auf die herkunft und auf die
damit verbundene einstellung hat im
osten sogar zugenommen und ich
abgenommen also und dann habe ich
sicherlich auch fehler im umgang mit
leuten begann das will ich auch alles
gar nicht bestreiten das einzige was
gibt's ein fehler den ich nicht begangen
habe oder doch indirekt ich wollte ja
immer die zusammenführen ich wollte
immer eine bestimmte harmonie erreichen
und vielleicht muss man auch manchmal
sagen es geht halt einfach nicht
zusammen und das dann eine minderheit
eben auch einfach geht und das hält man
dann aus und versucht nicht unbedingt
sie krampfhaft zu halten wenn es die
partei kaputt machen kann aber das ist
immer so schwer dass einzuschätzen weil
manchmal denn eine minderheit gehen
verlierst du manchmal kannst du auch
gewinnen das ist unterschiedlich aber
wofür ich jetzt streiten und das hat
mich vielleicht früher nicht so gemacht
weil ich selbst auch als problem gar
nicht gesehen habe dass völlig grabe für
die leute dass es die mehrheitsmeinung
der partei und eine minderheitsmeinung
wir müssen die minderheitspartei ich
hätte meine oder aussagen sind es bei
den linken was mehrheit und was
minderheit ist ja das ist genau die
frage man ringt ja um eine mehrheit aber
wenn es dann auf dem parteitag
beschlüsse gibt und dann weiß man wie
die mehrheit aussieht oder wenn es in
der fraktion eine klare mehrheit gibt
dann muss man nicht immer den kompromiss
mit der minderheit suchen sondern muss
man sagen so sieht die mehrheit aus und
das vertreten wäre es nach außen und die
minderheit kann ja gerne eine andere
auffassung haben ich war schon bei einer
einheitspartei ich will nicht wieder
dass wir alle die gleiche meinung haben
das gleiche denken fühlen sollen und
bleibt auch noch gleich aussehen also
das ganz bestimmt nicht aber ich möchte
dass eine mehrheit eben auch zur
mehrheitsentscheidung steht und die
minderheit dann sagt okay wir haben
keine mehrheit aber wir haben unsere
auffassung können sie ja sagen nur
deutlich muss es werden und das wurde
nicht mehr deutlich was ist denn zum
beispiel eine minderheitsposition in der
partei die linke das wird sich bei
verschiedenen fragen heraus stellen zb
zu flüchtlingen gab es unterschiedliche
auffassungen zum bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen gibt es unterschiedliche
auffassungen und da muss man immer die
mehrheiten feststellen und da muss die
bevölkerung wissen aha das ist die
mehrheitsmeinung und das ist die
minderheitsmeinung dann hat man auch
chancen gewählt zu werden wenn nämlich
sachen weil flüchtling das als
gleichwertig empfunden wird dann werden
sich die nicht wählen die für
flüchtlinge sind und auch nicht die idee
wählen die gegen flüchtlinge sind dann
christel gar keine wählerinnen und
wähler wenn ihr aber wissen haben das
ist die mehrheitsmeinung dass eine
positive haltung gegenüber flüchtlingen
und wir sind auch gegner von
flüchtlingen erster zweiter und dritter
klasse ist dann gibt es leute die sich
deshalb wählen wenn sie aber nicht
wissen ob das wirklich die
mehrheitsposition deswegen sie sich
nicht und die dagegen sind nur die
wenigsten auch nicht weise mit den
anderen teil der partei kennt das ist
nicht gut beispiel und bei bildungs
bedingungslosen grundeinkommen und so
weiter aber es gibt natürlich auch viele
übereinstimmende punkte weiß ich was
gegen prekäre beschäftigung für einen
höheren mindestlohn etc und das müssen
wir auch in den vordergrund stellen also
gewichten sich mit zentralen fragen
beschäftigen ganz klar sagen das ist die
mehrheitsmeinung gene ist eine
minderheitsmeinung und dann können wir
auch wieder stimmen von leuten gewinnen
die sich bei uns zu hause fühlen und das
niederträchtige was da geschrieben wird
was ich mit denen nation bezeichnet habe
das müssen wir überwinden zwar indem wir
den leuten einfach klarmachen sie
bringen sich um ihre eigene existenz sie
haben gerade gesagt dass sie auch fehler
gemacht haben im umgang mit personen wo
würden sie sagen da haben sie wirklich
einen fehler gemacht da sind sind das
will ich ihnen jetzt nicht als fehlen
auch nicht wenn sendung für nichts
persönliches
das ist mir zu persönlich das ist in zu
persönlich okay dann eine frage die auch
persönlich ist die sie aber wie sie
umtreibt auch selbst waren die linken
und sie persönlich zu russland
freundlich
ja das verstehe ich zumindest bei den
ostdeutschen das war bei den
westdeutschen gar nicht so ein problem
das lag natürlich an der beziehung zur
sowjetunion und an der art wie russland
behandelt wurde zb von dem bei dem von
uns zu recht scharf kritisierten krieg
der nato gegen serbien der ja
völkerrechtswidrig war und wo ja noch
jelzin strikt dagegen war und die nato
sich überhaupt nicht mehr für russland
interessiert hat das alles hatte
bestimmte konsequenzen dann entgegen
zwei-plus-vier-verhandlungen die
aufnahme von 14 weiteren
mitgliedsländern in die nato das
heranrücken der nato-truppen an russland
ich glaube keine sekunde dass die nato
russland über fällt dann wenn sie das
täten beim dritten weltkrieg mit den
katastrophalen folgen aber die russische
führung sei das eben anders fühlte sich
immer bedrängt und das hat vielleicht
dazu geführt dass wir tatsächlich eine
idee zu nachsichtig waren gegenüber den
inneren politischen veränderungen die er
immer autoritärer wurden deshalb sagen
ich hätte sie sage ach ich auch und
deshalb sage ich jetzt
wir müssen übrigens
menschenrechtsverletzungen immer
gleichermaßen kritisieren das macht die
regierung auch nicht bei einigen staaten
schaute weg bei einem land schaut zu
doppelt genau hin und wir dürfen nicht
den gleichen fehler machen sondern wir
müssen wirklich eine vertretung der
menschenrechte sein und zwar überall
egal ob sie in china verletzt werden
oder in russland verletzt werden oder an
katar oder saudi arabien wir müssen
immer einheitliche auffassung zu den
menschenrechten haben damit wir
glaubwürdig sind auf dieser schiene
aber jetzt ist es ganz klar muss man die
vergleichsweise angriffskrieg geführt
und der kann nur scharf verurteilt
werden der denkt eben genauso imperial
wie andere auch imperial gedacht haben
oder immer noch denken und das müssen
wir erkennen und das ist ja auch kein
sozialistisches land das ist ein staat
kapitalistisches land wenn immer
autoritären strukturen und da müssen wir
so was so im inneren einer seele
versteckt das müssen wir überwinden aber
nie ein staat mit der bevölkerung
gleichsetzen die russinnen großen mag
ich bin gerne mit ihnen auch gerne mit
ihnen zusammen aber ich mag ja auch die
amerikanerinnen und amerikaner spenden
mit denen auch gerne zusammen trotzdem
kritisiert die region aber es fällt auf
dass sie auf eine frage nach russland
doch immer wieder mit dem ganzen bild
antworten und auch immer wieder
vergleiche oder ähnliche situationen
anführen fällt ihnen das schwer wirklich
ganz explizit
gerade ihm gegenüber jetzt wirklich nur
zu russland stellung genommen aber die
vergleiche bieten es ist ja immer an und
wissen sie ich brauche die deshalb
meiner partei zu erklären wenn wir
unterschiedliche sichten je nach staat
an stellen sind wir nicht besser als die
regierung die ja doch bei saudi arabien
und katar er weg sieht und bei china und
russland genau hinsieht und genau das
dürfen wir nicht machen deshalb müssen
wir menschenrechtsverletzungen in china
in russland und in allen anderen staaten
immer gleichermaßen verurteilen dann
sind wir für die leute auch
glaubwürdiger als werden wir auch mal
wechseln oder nicht so genau hinschauen
und dem andante dann besonders gerne
hinschauen
jetzt wird es gerechte kriege muss man
eben immer verurteilt und sehen sie mal
wir haben das argument der nato nicht
gelten lassen dass im kosovo auch
zivilisten ums leben kann die serbische
armee kämpft er gegen die usa die wollte
er bewaffnet das kosovo von serbien
trennen jeder stadt findet sich dagegen
wehren aber es kamen auch zivilisten ums
leben
russland sagt ja verschiedene begründung
aber eine begründung ist auch dass es ja
bewaffnete kämpfe zwischen bewaffneten
kräften im donbass gab die hat natürlich
debatten von russland und die
ukrainische armee hat dagegen gekämpft
aber es sind auch zivilisten ums leben
gekommen und das argument wirklich
akzeptiert nun sage ich zu meinen läuten
wenn wir das argument der nato nicht
akzeptiert haben können wir heute auch
nicht das argument russlands akzeptieren
abgesehen davon dass es schon viele tote
verletzte und zerstörung gibt ich war im
land ich habe mir das ja nähe sehen das
ist wirklich grauenvoll was man da sehen
muss einfach was geschehen ist und das
sag ich es immer und die frage der
glaubwürdigkeit wenn ich das eine
verurteilung muss sich auch das andere
ganz entschieden verurteilt und dann
gibt es natürlich auch unterschiede aber
auf die will ich jetzt gar nicht weiter
heiligen abends glaubwürdigkeit hängt
immer davon arbeitet sich gleiche
massstäbe ansetzte oder nicht sie waren
im land das haben sie gerade gesagt
jetzt ist es ja so dass die 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr so gut wie beschlossen sind
und olaf scholz angekündigt hat
modernste flugabwehrsysteme an die
ukraine liefern zu wollen beides findet
nicht die zustimmung der linken die
linken lehnen es ab warum noch mal ganz
kurz
bei dem waffenlieferungen geht es mir um
unsere geschichte wir haben den
schlimmsten krieg der welt
menschheitsgeschichte ausgelöste im
zweiten weltkrieg mit 50 millionen toten
und deshalb suchen wir nie wieder
einkriegen verdient wir sind aber der
fünf größter waffenexporteur der welt
wir verdienen an jedem krieg in syrien
libanon
libyen
nehmen
die türkei führt völkerrechtswidrige
kriege gegen die kurdinnen und kurden in
syrien und auch im irak da sagt die
regierung übrigens nichts dazu wir
verurteilen dass er und wir verdienen
auch wieder daran weil wir erwarten an
die türkei verkaufen und deshalb sage
ich deutschland soll überhaupt keine
waffen exportieren mithin auch nicht zur
verwirklichung des
selbstverteidigungsrecht in der ukraine
andere länder haben eine andere
geschichte die können das machen wir
können das gleiche geld aufwendig dass
wir dann besser gestellt sind für
humanitäre hilfe aber das begründe ich
historisch die 100 milliarden sind doch
einfach unsinn entschuldigen sie die
wollen auch von 50 milliarden auf 75
milliarden gehen jedes jahr für rüstung
und armee die begründung sind einmal
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten hätten
keine warme unterwäsche die panzer
rollen nicht die schiffe fahren nicht
die flugzeuge fliegen nicht frankreich
gibt dasselbe geld aus der armee da
haben die warme unterwäsche die panzer
rollen die flugzeuge fliegen und die
schiffe fahren also muss man nicht mehr
geld ausgeben sondern sich mal um die
art der verbindung das geld ist kümmern
jahrhundert bei der ukraine also
wirklich genau bei dem thema ganz kurze
weil sie sind natürlich jetzt in der
komfortableren situation nicht agieren
zu müssen sondern als opposition
natürlich ein bisschen mit abstand
draufklicken können wenn sie das nicht
muss zudem 100 milliarden sagen deswegen
können sie das gerne gleich noch mal
wenn sie sich jetzt für moment
vorstellen sie wären mich in der
opposition sondern müssten wirklich
tatsächlich handeln und die
verantwortung dafür tragen wir würden
sie bei der gleichen position bleiben
und würden sagen deutschland ist das
land was keine waffen liefern dass keine
waffen liefert aber den gleichen aufwand
betreibt wie andere angemessen und wir
übernehmen die humanitäre hilfe andere
länder haben eine andere geschichte wie
haben hitler gestellt sie haben gegen
hitler gekämpft das ist ein großer
unterschied aber das zweite ist ein
angriff russlands auf deutschland
befürchte ich keine sekunde aber selbst
wenn er tatsächlich käme wäre das der
dritte weltkrieg dann müssten die usa
frankreich großbritannien alle nato
mitgliedsländer sofort eingreifen wir
hätten den dritten weltkrieg dann können
sie die ausrüstung über 100 milliarden
sowieso vergessen dann gehen wir unter
also mit anderen worten wir müssen doch
umgekehrt
an einen russland nach putin denken an
die beendigung des krieges senden es
wird doch auch in russland nach putin
geben und meine frage ist wie wollen wir
denn zu einer neuen friedensordnung und
europa kommt mit deeskalation abrüstung
gestellt nicht aufrüsten wenn ihr auf
kosten müssten doch die chinesen wieder
weiter auf die russen werden nach ende
des krieges auf wieder aufrüsten etc und
also nochmal die eskalation abrüstung
interessenausgleich es gibt ja nicht nur
um unsere interessen sondern auch die
interessen des gegenüber aber wir mehr
diplomatie und strikter wahrung des
völkerrechts durch alle aber durch würde
denn jetzt deeskaliert werden können das
ist im augenblick sehr schwer macht eben
der krieg begonnen hat ich hoffe aber
ich weiß es nicht ich hoffe auf
geheimdiplomatie ich hoffe dass es
wenigstens zwischen den usa und russland
keine diplomatie gibt dass bestimmte
rote linie nicht überschritten werden
ich hoffe ein bisschen auf die neutralen
staaten dass die sich einsetzen und
irgendwelche kompromisse vorschlagen
italien hat er jetzt mal kompromiss
vorgeschlagen österreich hatte ein paar
ideen ich glaube wir müssen viel stärker
wieder diplomatie einsetzen damit
wenigstens ein waffenstillstand in kraft
tritt und das muss intensiviert werden
aber wir reden ja den waffen waffen
waffen und sanktionen sanktion
sanktionen und was anderes fällt uns
nicht ein und das hat hinkriegt bisher
nicht beendet im gegenteil
aber halt wenn sie sagen sie es bleibt
ihnen jetzt gerade nur das prinzip
hoffnung ist das natürlich etwas wenn
sie sich jetzt vorstellen sie sind jetzt
noch mal in der ukraine und die menschen
treten auf sie zu und sagen was kann
deutschland machen und sie sagen ich
hoffe darauf dass es geheimdiplomatie
knallen das will ich ihnen ja nicht
sagen dann würde ich sagen was wir
liefern sehen sie mal wir waren in den
krankenhäuser wir haben uns die küchen
angeschaut wir haben festgestellt dass
im krieg eine ungeheure solidarität der
menschen entsteht und auch geduld wie
sitzen zwei stunden drei stunden zucht
denn ich werde das macht ihn gar nichts
aus sie werden nicht mal schlecht
gelaunt dabei wirklich erstaunlich wenn
ich gerade besucht darüber nachdenke wie
das bei uns läuft und wir haben ihnen ja
spenden gebracht und wir haben ihnen
medizinische geräte gebracht und wir
haben gefragt was sie benötigen es
bringt in immer nicht zentral du
schickst mullbinden hin aber die
brauchen sie gar nicht sie brauchen was
ganz anderes das haben wir das alles
konkret aufgeschrieben ich habe schon
eine bundeswirtschaftsminister
geschrieben weil an einer bestimmten
stelle zum beispiel dringend traktoren
benötigt werden etc wir sammeln jetzt
spenden um wirklich konkrete hilfe
leisten zu können und sie haben aber zur
kenntnis genommen dass ich gegen
deutsche waffenlieferungen bin aber
nicht gegen ihr selbstverteidigungsrecht
ich sage es nochmal andere länder haben
da andere geschichte und wenn wir aber
das gleiche an humanitäre hilfe leisten
dann sind sie dafür glaube ich auch
dankbar also wir wurden nur schlecht
behandelt ganz im gegenteil sie haben ja
eben schon anklingen lassen es braucht
ein russland ohne putin
das nach nach putin wie kommt man aus
ihrer sicht dahin ich glaube dass er den
anfang seines endes eingeleitet hat wenn
du autoritäre strukturen hast brauchst
du ein apparat der gestützt und hält und
er hat begonnen den apparat zu verlieren
nicht die bevölkerung die medien hype
liegt ja nicht bei uns die liegt hier
bei putin aber der apparat der wird
immer zerbrechlicher und der wird immer
anfälliger woran machen sie das fest da
ist da ich ja bestimmte leute kenne als
hin die mir das natürlich auch und sagen
welche veränderung ist dort gibt ich
weiß nicht wie schnell es geht aber ich
weiß irgendwann haben wir ein russland
nach putin wir müssen anders als die
nato gemacht hat die
sicherheitsinteressen dieses russlands
auch ernst nehmen und jede vorstellung
eines wieder einer wiederherstellung des
alten zarenreiches territorial ist
absurd das verstößt gegen alles
internationale recht das muss in
russland überwunden werden überhaupt
müssen wir weltweit das imperiale denken
überwinden aber eben auch bei russland
meiner partei muss begreifen dass ist ja
putin genauso imperial denkt wie andere
und genau das ist die katastrophe ja ich
glaube ja auch er wollte die ganze
ukraine das hat dann begriffen dass er
die nichtchristen würden versuchen dass
das gebiet zu bekommen und ein streifen
bis zur krim und dann stehen die ukraine
wieder vor der frage was machen sie
jetzt mit der situation alles sehr
spannend und da hoffe ich einfach auf
geheimdiplomatie lässt man irgendwas
findet wo man sagt wir akzeptieren das
juristisch nicht aber jetzt hat
aufgehört zu schießen wir gehen von der
situation oder b aus und da haben wir
auch kein recht der ukrainischen führung
vorschriften zu machen wenn sie sich auf
einen kompromiss einlässt egal ob uns
beiden der gefällt oder nicht gefällt
haben wir das zu respektieren hauptsache
es wird nicht mehr geschossen die sache
kommt die frage wie können wir eine neue
free zone europa herstellen sie sind ja
genau für diese annäherung zu russland
jahre lang eingetreten jetzt sind wir in
einer ganz anderen situation sie auch
gerade beschrieben haben haben sie den
eindruck dass einiges für das was sie
für sie gekämpft haben vergeblich war
naja der bruch zwischen der nato und
russland begann mit dem völkerrecht für
den krieg der nato gegen jugoslawien
jelzin war damals noch der präsident
strikt dagegen und das hat die natur
nicht interessiert sie dürfen nicht
vergessen es gibt ein
sicherheitsratsbeschluss also mit
zustimmung aller fünf veto mächte auch
großbritannien frankreich und usa dass
das kosovo einen hohen an autonomie
benötigt aber bestandteil serbiens
bleiben muss und das hat die nato
interessiert sich wir trennen das
einfach das sind immer da habe ich
damals der regierung gesagt ihr fangt an
mit völkerrechts von den hochschulen
nicht bestritten dass das
völkerrechtsverletzungen sind andere
werden folgen und deshalb bin ich so
viel strikter wahrung des völkerrechts
immer und deshalb kann ich dass china
nicht durchgehen lassen und anderen
nicht etwa in russland nicht durchgehen
lassen und anderen nicht durchgehen
lassen wenn sie das völkerrecht
verletzen auf der türkei nicht wie es
jetzt macht und das problem ist
dass das damals alles unterschätzen ist
ich sag ja immer die nato und die eu
haben in bezug auf die ukraine fast
alles falsch gemacht was man falsch
machen kann auch in bezug auf russland
nur sie haben keinen einzigen fehler
begangen der diesen schrecklichen
verbrecherischen völkerrechtswidrigen
angriffskrieg russlands gegen die
ukraine rechtfertigte die linke jetzt
ihre haltung zum nato ändern das weiß
ich nicht wir werden sehen auf jeden
fall wissen sie es natürlich habe ich
nach wie vor eine kritische haltung zur
nato und natürlich möchte ich dass wir
neutrale staaten haben wie finnland und
schweden bei berlin für die vermittlung
brauchen nun wollen sie aber in die nato
und nun kann ich dir sagen ist glaube
keine sekunde dass russland euch
angreift sein werden die mehr sagen
haben sich beide ukraine geglaubt muss
ich sagen nein habe ich nicht und ist
die ukraine über veränderungen muss ich
sagen ja so was sage ich ihnen dann also
verstehen sie da stehen wir auch
zwischen baum und borke dass wir müssen
ja unsere kritische haltung zur nato
nicht ändern wir müssen auch nicht
ändern und
sein wunsch dass es möglichst viele
staaten gibt die nicht militärisch
neutral sind die militärisch neutral
stellen die nicht in blöcke gehen wir
können auch keine blog politik
gebrauchen sagen wir mal russland china
vielleicht sogar noch indien gegen den
rest der welt das ging auch nicht auch
noch kann es so alles richtig nur was
antwort durch den regierung in finnland
und schweden das frage ich meine partei
und wir müssen eine antwort wird der
kann denn diese antworten für die linke
finden also wer ist die starke figur die
jetzt bei der linken zur integration ist
und die eine sympathische partei da geht
zur mehrheitsbildung aber ein paar dinge
muss man korrigieren dazu werde ich mich
auch äußern noch haben wir ja nicht dem
parteitag jetzt hat der sahra
wagenknecht sich schon geäußert und eine
neuausrichtung gefordert so wie es jetzt
ist dürfte es nicht weitergehen sagt
sehe und die partei müsse sich mehr für
die mehrheit der bevölkerung einsetzen
sich nicht auf bestimmte milieus
verengen das deckt sich mit dem was sie
auch eingangs gesagt haben ist es so
dass die linke jetzt die starken figuren
die sie die letzten jahre hatte sie
sagen nicht dass nur sie jetzt
tatsächlich die partei wieder ein stück
nach vorne bringen können oder ist
janine wissler die richtige person also
erstens ist janine wissler unsere
vorsitzende und wir müssen schon deshalb
mit ihm solidarisch sein weil ja der
spiegel versucht hat sie fertig zu
machen dann müssen wir immer eine gegen
haltung einnehmen und solidarität zeigen
zweitens schlage persönlichkeiten können
immer ihren beitrag leisten aber sie
sollten sich auch nicht überschätzen sie
wollen in deutschland
liegen oder ist das nicht das bei janine
wissler sind es jetzt die medien
weswegen sie sich sozusagen hinter sie
stellen oder ist es dass sie sagen sie
hat in der affäre in hessen kein fehler
gemacht wissen sie bei solchen
persönlichen dingen ist es immer sehr
schwer über fehler zu reden einer vom
schulrat zu mir gesagt warum hat sich
keiner versammlung der fraktionen
gemacht also stellen sie sich mal vor
sie haben lernen hier bei phoenix einen
mann kennen sie lieben den mann er
arbeitet bei phoenix sie arbeiten bei
phoenix und dann betrügt ja sie und dann
sollen sie in der versammlung machen und
sagen ich möchte ich euch mal erzählt
was mein mann so 3
das geht gar nicht so funktioniert das
nicht arbeitsrechtlich konnte sie auch
nichts machen das wäre die vermischung
von privatangelegenheiten mit dienst
angelegenheiten nicht sie hat betrogen
sondern sie wurde betrogen das heißt sie
das hatten sie hat gut und entschieden
daher das habe ich nicht gesagt gut und
entschieden aber sie waren einer äußerst
schwierigen situation und das wird
überhaupt nicht bedacht dabei und da ich
rechtsanwalt bin kenne ich leute die in
solchen schwierigen situation sind und
da bin ich sehr vorsichtig mit
ratschlägen wie man damit umgehen soll
und wenn man selber mal in solchen
schwierigen situationen war oder sie
herbei geführt hat warum auch immer
weiss man wie schwierig das es zu
reagieren und deshalb sage ich mal nicht
der spiegel hat zu entscheiden wer bei
uns vorsitzendes wir haben das zu
entscheiden wollen
stärkere rolle wieder spielen auf gar
keinen fall werde ich wieder
vorsitzender der partei uns immerzu ich
bin 74 jahre man muss an die nächste
generation übergeben das haben wir auch
gemacht und die müssen natürlich
irgendwann auch übergeben und wir müssen
uns eben gedanken machen wie wir jetzt
eine führungsstruktur zusammenstellen
die das leistet was ich ihnen versucht
habe anfangs zu erklären was für
unbedingt leisten müssen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch herr
gesät wird
[Musik]